hey this is presto Walker the 1942
textbook differential equations by Ralph
Palmer Agnew has a seemingly impossible
math problem I came across a problem on
Roy Wright's blog here's the problem one
day it started snowing in the morning at
a heavy and steady rate a snow plow
started out at noon going two miles in
the first hour and one mile in the
second hour what time did it start
snowing say what the textbook even
acknowledges how the problem sounds
quote our first task is to try to
recover from the shock of being asked to
solve such a problem by attempting to
analyze the problem so in real life we
don't often get every single assumption
we have to make some modeling
assumptions so in this case we're going
to assume the snow plow speed is
inversely proportional to the height of
snow that is fallen the more snow that
falls the slower the snowplow moves and
with this one assumption we can actually
solve this problem very specifically
using calculus so it still looks pretty
impossible but what do you think can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for a solution
so we'll start out with some notation
we'll let T 2 note the time measured
from noon in hours we'll let X of T be
the distance the snowplow has traveled
we'll let H of T be the height of snow
in inches and we'll let B be the number
of hours before noon that it started
snowing finally we'll at case of 1b the
rate of snowfall in inches per hour so
we know that it started snowing at a
heavy and steady rate so the change in
height of snow is the constant k1 we can
solve this using integral calculus this
will be a linear equation the height of
snow is k1 times T plus some constant
now we know that at be hours before noon
the height of snow is zero so H of
negative B be hours before noon we
substitute that in and set it equal to
zero so we can solve that the constant
is equal to k1 times B this makes sense
for B hours it's snowed k1 times B
inches of snow so the height of snow at
t is equal to k1 times T plus k1 times B
this is k1 times the quantity T plus B
now where do we go from here now we know
the snowplow speed is inversely
proportional to the height of snow so
the product of the speed of the snowplow
and the height of the snow is a constant
k2 this is some unknown constant k2 it's
not going to matter for the purposes of
this problem well now say that the speed
of the snowplow is equal to k2 divided
by the height of the snow we know the
height of the snow is equal to k1 times
the quantity T plus B and now we'll take
those two constants K 2 and K 1 and
we'll just make them another
k-3 again this constant is not going to
matter for the ultimate solution but
we'll just say k3 is equal to k2 over k1
to make this a little simpler to write
so now we have a differential equation
for the speed of the snowplow and this
is separable so we can solve it by
integrating both sides we get that the
distance of snowplow has traveled is
equal to k3 times the natural log of the
quantity T plus B plus some arbitrary
constant now rather than solve for this
constant we're gonna do a neat little
trick we're gonna use the information
that's given so we know that the
snowplow travels two miles in the first
hour therefore X of one is equal to two
and that's also equal to this
antiderivative evaluated between 0 and 1
so we say 2 is equal to this
antiderivative evaluated at 1 minus the
antiderivative evaluated at 0 and we can
simplify using the rules of logarithms
to get that 2 is equal to K 3 times the
quantity the natural log of the fraction
1 plus B all over B so we've used one
piece of information now let's use the
other piece of information we get an
extra 1 mile in the second hour so the
distance traveled between the second
hour X 2 and the first hour X 1 is equal
to 1 X of 2 minus X 1 is equal to 1 and
this will be equal to this
antiderivative evaluated from 1 to 2 so
we evaluate this antiderivative and
using the rules of logarithms we get
that 1 is equal to K 3 times the natural
log of the fraction 2 plus B all over 1
plus B so how is this going to help us
well let's take a look at these two
expressions what we can do is we can
multiply the second expression by
- so we have two is equal to two times K
three times the natural log of this
fraction and using the rules of
logarithms we can take this two and
raise it as the exponent so now we have
two different expressions for two and we
can divide both of these by the constant
k3 so we can say that 2 divided by K 3
is equal to the first expression the
natural log of 1 plus B all over B and
it's also equal to the second expression
we have the natural log of 2 plus B all
over 1 plus B and we want that quantity
to be squared so we'll take these 2
natural log expressions which are equal
to each other and we can say in order
for them to be equal we must have that
their arguments are equal to each other
so we have the quantity 1 plus B all
over B must be equal to the quantity 2
plus B all over 1 plus B that whole
quantity squared so you now take these
fractions and cross multiply so we get
the quantity 1 plus b cubed is equal to
b times the quantity 2 plus b squared we
can now expand out we can then cancel
out like terms and simplify to get the
quadratic equation b squared plus b
minus 1 is equal to 0 now we can solve
this very readily we use a quadratic
equation and we get two possibilities
for B we have B is equal to
approximately 0.618 or b is equal to
approximately negative 1.618
now which one is the correct answer well
B is the hours before noon when it
started snowing so B has to be a
positive number so we reject the
negative solution so finally we convert
B from hours into minutes so a B is
approximately 0.618
hours we multiply that by 60 to get 37
minutes
therefore it started snowing about 37
minutes before noon or at 11:23 a.m. and
we've solved the seemingly impossible
problem using calculus did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions if you like
this video you can check out my books
which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon if you have a math topic or a
puzzle you can email me pres at mind
your decisions calm and you can catch me
either at mind your decisions or at
pressure Walker on social media